this fox leared a staple of global
politics stable really of for so many
decades Henry Kissinger tonight sad news
dead at the age of 100 now secretary
Kissinger worked under multiple
administrations he won the Nobel Peace
Prize for negotiating a ceasefire in
Vietnam uh there's so many other
accomplishments this man has had his
life background and his experience uh is
is really Beyond inspiring he was a
Jewish Refugee he fled Nazi Germany with
his family
1938 he arrived in the United States He
excelled academically graduated from
Harvard uh and earned an Ma and PhD
degrees at at Harvard uh really really
somebody that that so many look up to in
so many different ways and accomplished
so much um but really um you know became
a household name he Ser served under two
Republican presidents one being Richard
Nixon the other being Gerald Ford he
advised powerful leaders in both the
American political parties for decades
uh he was advising presidents up until
recently he came to be seen as perhaps
one of the most prominent leading
diplomats and international relations
intellects of the 20th century um and
orchestrated the normalization of
relations with China during the Nixon
presidency helped these tensions between
the US and the Soviet Union at some of
the tougher moments during the Cold War
he won that Nobel Peace prize for
negotiating that settlement that ended
the Vietnam War um what a life that he
has he has led uh and was so
instrumental in that that the relations
opening diplomatic relations between the
US and China uh something up to that
point not really doable or thinkable uh
during the Nixon Administration one of
the most you know also he had a share of
enemies and detractors uh for a lot of
reasons most of it having to do with
Vietnam joining us now with reaction of
the sad news tonight is Fox News
contributor Ari fler Ari um I've had the
pleasure of interviewing him I've had
the pleasure of having just general
conversation with him and it wasn't that
long ago the last conversation we had
and he was as sharp as he ever was um
amazing man an amazing life and again
our prayers are with his family
tonight and you know Sean it was for
anybody who did get to know him it
really was a pleasure he was such an
intellect such a force to just to listen
to his knowledge of history and his
ability to sum up conclusions you know I
got to know him in November of 2002 if
you remember this probably very few
people do he was actually named to be
the chairman of the 911 Commission and
then after he was named Senator George
Mitchell was going to be the Democrat
co-chair of the 9911 commission they
both realized neither one of them wanted
to do it so Henry kissen drafty realized
all the things he'd have to step down
from all the conflicts of interest he he
spent a lot of time with me talking to
me about this asking for my advice
should he proceed with this what's going
to happen with all these other endeavors
that he is in the middle of and I told
him the Press will kill you you can't
have any other endeavors the Press will
say it's a conflict of interest and and
it really got to him because he wanted
to serve he didn't want the Press
controversy and I was honored that he
thought enough to ask for my advice and
listen you know that that was one thing
about him I remember very distinctly
it's interesting you say that um at a
particular event I I had an opportunity
to speak one-on-one with him and he
started asking me questions I'm like I
should be asking you questions because
of his you know incredible background um
when you think of in light of what's
going on in the world today especially
the rise of anti-Semitism and he escaped
Nazi Germany uh I would have liked to
have had that conversation with him
about because I didn't think we'd ever
see this in our lifetime I'm sure you
you think the same way Ari
yeah absolutely Sean and and you know I
did get to talk to him about things of
that nature because after the white
house uh when I moved back to New York
he and I would go to lunch sometimes and
sitting at a lunch table just the two of
us I would ask him those kind of
questions I would ask him about his life
I'd ask him about coming to America the
opportunities of America being Jewish
and it really was a fascinating
conversation for me just to sit there
and almost be not a reporter but I was
The Inquisitor asking him things and
that's where I just really grew my
respect for his intellect he was already
up in his age at that time I haven't
seen him for about 10 years now but I
suspect he was sharp to the end but what
a life story Sean and he loved the
United States he loved the United States
cuz he recognized what opportunity was
you know he he recently he was he was in
a wheelchair and it seemed like he had
just given a speech and this is going
back maybe a month month and a half ago
and and some liberal reporter was was
asking him contentious questions and
like the pro he was he just ignored it
and got in the car and drove off um but
you're right what a life he lived you
know sometimes maybe we get a little
locked into where we are now in this
moment and we lose historical
perspective you know but he lived
through the Vietnam era that means the
60s we know a lot of horrible things
happen in this country a Great Divide in
this country
uh in the 60s look at all the people
assassinated in the 60s um you think of
of you know the hippie movement you
think of the early 70s the nition years
Vietnam this was a divided country back
then too
Ari no question about it 1968 in many
ways was the worst year we've had and
worse than 2020 with the George Floyd
riots and Co and everything else that
took place 68 at at the height of Nixon
and and Vietnam at Etc and you know
Henry Kissinger was the wise man who got
the United States through so much of
that as you said when he opened up
relations with China something was
absolutely unheard of impossible to do
he did it and it's a different China
back then than it is now but there were
just certain things that were impossible
in foreign policy and I don't think
Henry Kissinger ever accepted the word
impossible his life was a possibility
Coming to America was a possibility he
saw what the United States States
represented and relished it and that's
why I think the word impossible was
never in Henry Kissinger's vocabulary
because the life he led but also the
mind Sean and this is what I got to know
about him the mind that he had didn't
see limits he just saw opportunities in
places and in ways other people did not
see they may have seen a a dead end or a
roadblock he said I'll get over that
yeah China Vietnam uh he played such an
important role historically at a a very
divided time in this country's hist
history Ari we appreciate you staying
with us thank you uh joining us now on
the phone is Brett Bear uh host of
Special Report Brett Let's uh get your
initial reaction to this uh what a
towering figure he was what an
incredible life he led a hundred years
old and my last conversation with him he
was as sharp as
ever Sean he uh was as sharp as can be
even in the end I mean there were people
were clamoring to to him to say you know
what do you think about this what do you
think about this he served as National
Security advisor and Secretary of State
under President Richard nick uh Richard
Nixon and then under Joe Ford but as you
say he
was really a a foreign policy Guru
for administrations a lot of them after
that
I saw him last uh when he was at Charles
Crow Hammer's lunch I came there Charles
asked me to a lunch and uh I got there
and uh there was kissing Kissinger and
we spent the entire lunch talking about
everything around the world he was an
amazing person who understood foreign
policy from a lot of different spec
spectrums a lot of different uh
perspectives and like Charles crammer
had he could cut through the noise you
know yeah you know it's interesting we
we use the term frequently called
shuttle diplomacy well he conducted the
first shuttle diplomacy in his quest for
Middle East peace uh he used secret
channels to pursue the ties between the
US and China at that point ending what
was decades of isolation and and nothing
but hostility between the two countries
uh he initiated the the Paris
negotiations that ultimately providing
provided the the means for an interval
as he called it to get the us out of
Vietnam it was two years later that
Saigon fell to the Communists uh he was
the one that pursued the policy of dayon
with the former Soviet Union leading to
Arms Control agreements and raised the
possibilities that the tensions of the
Cold War and its nuclear threat not have
to last forever um at 99 he was still
out on a book Tour on leadership I mean
um I mean some of the the most sensitive
foreign policy negotiations he was a
part of and frankly p uh a Trailblazer
in
this and he had that ability to talk in
his deep voice that was a baritone voice
that cut through the noise was and he
would um there were people who were
looking for his
advice up until 99 up until 100 and it
was truly amazing to see that he was
that strong in foreign policy all these
years and uh you know I I talked to him
probably a few months ago and uh he
still had it you know but Brett I'll
tell you one fun funny story you know
that I try to do these imitations I
don't think they're that great but I one
time did my imitation of him to him I
talk about bottom policy you know I I I
said that to him and he laughed he had a
great sense of humor on top of
everything
else he did and uh if you could
do Henry Kissinger if you could
do you know I can't do I can't do it
Sean well it would be uh we talk about
botom policy you know that's the way he
did it and he he' come on Hannity and
Colmes with with Allen and myself and
back in the day too um he was just a
giant of a man Heart of Gold brilliant
mind uh to the very end uh Brett we
really appreciate you taking time thanks
for being with us tonight you bet all
right sad news one of America's
legendary diplomats former Secretary of
State Henry Kissinger died at the age of
100 while Kissinger has passed away his
legacy that will live on forever let's
take a look back with his towering
intellect in ruthless real politic his
dazzling shuttle diplomacy and obsession
with his own image Henry Kissinger was
perhaps the most gifted admired and
reviled American Diplomat of the 20th
century there is no country in the world
where it is conceivable that a man of my
Origins could be standing here next to
the president of the United States a
refugee from Hitler's Germany Kissinger
immigrated to the United States in 1938
after serving in Army Counter
Intelligence in World War II he earned
three Harvard degrees Kissinger's
seminal 1957 book on nuclear strategy
earned him consultancies to the Kennedy
and Johnson white houses Dr Kissinger is
a man who is known to all people who are
interested in foreign policy as
President Nixon's first-term National
Security adviser Kissinger negotiated to
end the Vietnam War while the
commander-in-chief withdrew US troops
and secretly bombed Cambodia another
20,000 US troops and countless
Vietnamese perished in the four years
before Kissinger famously declared peace
is at hand and received the Nobel Peace
Prize when the Cambodia bombings leaked
to the Press Kissinger colluded in White
House wire Taps it's to get into to
revitalize our alliances to get into a
new relationship with the
Soviet to begin to feel our way towards
the Chinese for Nixon's historic trip to
China in 1972 it was Kissinger secret
overseas flights that paav the way and
their pursuit of deant with the Soviet
Union led to Major AR Arms Control
Accords astonishing breakthroughs that
Ern Kissinger brought a claim but
enduring suspicion among conservatives
who later argued he and Nixon should
have sought like Ronald Reagan to defeat
the Soviet Union in the uh early 1970s I
don't remember any conservative even
talking about defeating the Soviet Union
before one could even consider some of
the aspects of Reagan's policy Vietnam
had to be finished you can make it's
good a case for the fact that communism
was ultimately defeated by the poist
that Nixon started than by the polies
that Reagan enunciated and that Reagan
could never have done what he did if
Nixon had not first held the fort
created the structure throughout his
service to Nixon Kissinger publicly
heaped Praise on the president in public
a certain heroic quality about how he
conducts his business but ridiculing him
in private and ultimately taking a more
measured view of his partner in power he
lacked the capacity to to reach out to
people as individuals the way uh almost
all the candidates that I've known did
so naturally I shall testify with
respect to all matters confirmed as
Secretary of State in 1973 Kissinger
shuttle diplomacy helped end the yam
kapor war after Nixon resigned Kissinger
stayed on a reassuring figure amid the
upheaval of Watergate and also for a
Time an improbable celebrity Bachelor
Hollywood actresses drawn to the famous
Diplomat who called power the ultimate
aphrodesiac yet lawsuits and controversy
would dog Kissinger for decades after he
left power in 1977 liberals called him a
war criminal claiming he had coddled
right-wing dictators and was culpable in
the assassination of two Chilean
officials charges Kissinger denied
unfazed the Elder Statesman trotted the
globe a wealthy consultant his Council
widely sought he could be critical of US
policy we have to stop lecturing the
Russians uh on our concept of Reform I
think what is lacking is a clear
definition of what the purpose of our
China policy is but Kissinger supported
President Bush's muscular response to
911 and the Iraq War we are going to sit
there and let weapons of mass
destruction pile up in a country that
has already used them against its
neighbors and its own people against
which we fought a war 10 years
ago in 2014 he gathered with five other
secretaries of State for the
groundbreaking of the United States
diplomacy Center and to the last he
remained active in foreign policy
discourse writing a book called World
Order reviewed favorably in the
Washington Post by Hillary Clinton who
like all of Kissinger's successors Drew
on his Council when she served as
America's Secretary of State Henry K for
war crime arrest Henry kinger for war
crime agitators continued hounding
Kissinger as at this Senate armed
services Committee hearing in early 2015
prompting Senator John McCain a Vietnam
veteran to defend the one-time architect
of US policy there get out of here you
lowlife scum I'd like to apologize for
allowing such uh disgraceful
Behavior towards a man who served his
country with the greatest distinction
lifelong student of balance of power
politics a claimed author of more than a
dozen books and embattled subject of
dozens more Henry Kissinger engaged
every major foreign policy crisis across
Decades of service and commentary and
stro the world stage with an authority
and Charisma matched by few other
unelected figures in American history in
Washington Rich Edson Fox
News all right joining us now on the
phone someone who knew Dr Kissinger very
well uh our friend Monica Crowley is
with us uh Monica thank you for being
with us a lot of people may not know
about your background but post
presidency uh you worked for a long time
very closely with Richard Nixon and you
were also very close to Henry Kissinger
uh tell us about the man you knew and
the man that that Richard Nixon spoke
of yes thank you Sean um first of all my
deepest sympathy is to Mrs Kissinger and
the rest of the Kissinger family he
lives such a long and substantial life
um and it's never easy to lose someone
and I considered uh Henry Kissinger a
friend so I am very saddened by this
news yeah you know Sean my very first
job out of college was with the former
president Richard Nixon and during that
period of time I got to know a whole
array of heads of state around the world
and and other diplomats and Statesmen
and the one of course that stood out
apart from President Nixon was Dr
Kissinger and Sean I will tell you the
very first time I spoke to him I was you
know early 20s and fresh out of college
and I remember sitting with President
Nixon in his study in his office and the
phone rang and it was Dr Kissinger and
over the intercom uh Nick assistant said
I have Dr Kissinger on the phone for you
and so I went to get up to give him some
privacy to take the call and he waved me
back down into my chair Sean he said sit
and he picked up the phone and he said
Henry and the two of them spoke for a
couple of minutes and they often spoke a
couple of times a week about the state
of the world and what American foreign
policy was and what it should be and at
one point in the conversation Sean he
said Henry I want you to speak to my new
foreign policy assistant Monica Crowley
say hello to her and then she the phone
receiver toward me and I'm 21 22 years
old she Dred it toward me and I ended up
talking to Henry Kissinger in front of
Richard Nixon and it was a complete
outof body experience these two men
working together in the white house and
then beyond two towering intellect Sean
who work together to Advance America's
interests in the world what a tremendous
partnership well I can't say it any
better well said what a life experience
for you too Monica uh our thoughts and
prayers go out to his family tonight hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else